is that when you were an extra in shyia
lauffs art piece yeah you know I SI some
of the Shia Kool-Aid I'm 20 years old
I'm in New York I see sh buff popup
thing he will be there was it like
chanting what was it
yes yes it was like har Krishna for sh
buff like so you 100% would have joined
a shy buff cult at I mean that was a
cult then he's getting arrested and I'm
up at the camera I'm like he will not
let sh
go I'm there I'm right in the front I'm
putting my hand up I drew a heart on my
hand like he will not divide us he will
not divide us like you know that video
you know that you know you have a heart
for sh yeah and you know you know that
like famous image of the girl with the
flower in the gun I I thought I was
doing that you're thinking in images
like that yeah I'm like this is going to
be huge going be iconic this is going
down in history